when I heard president Trump had
insulted Haiti in the Oval Office the
president asked quote why are we having
all these people from [ __ ] countries
come here referring to African countries
and Haiti the president then went on to
talk about how they needed to bring in
more people from places like Norway now
I have no idea what the president has
against the people of Haiti but if the
president doesn't like them they must be
lovely people they really I mean it's
just a day later I was exchanging
dollars for Haitian gewd and before I
knew it I was in port-au-prince
receiving a warm welcome and a bottle of
rum now this will last me this morning
to understand today's Haiti you need to
know its history this should only take a
minute and 23 seconds before the
Europeans came Haiti was inhabited by
the indigenous Taino people than the
Spanish arrived conquer tetanus blended
their gold and brought in thousands of
African slaves then the French did the
same thing when they took over then in
1804 Toussaint Leavitt or and
jean-jacques Dessalines led a slave
revolt defeated the French and the
nation of Haiti was born but France
demanded reparations and Haiti had to
pay them 91 million gold francs all the
while the poor black majority fought
with the small but wealthy mulatos
dividing Haiti until in 1915 the u.s.
invaded to impose stability while also
removing the gold from the Haitian
National Bank when the u.s. withdrew
Haiti was led by military Quinta's and
mostly corrupt presidents including
Francois Papa Doc Duvalier and his son
jean-claude baby doc Duvalier who for
the next 30 years siphoned hundreds of
millions of dollars out of the country
and were followed by a military
government or appointed president's
military rulers and elected leaders more
military of rulers another election then
a coup d'etat a UN peacekeeping force
and more contested elections then a
devastating earthquake which killed
hundreds of thousands of Haitians
followed by food shortages an outbreak
of cholera and devastation by hurricanes
in short the people of Haiti have been
dealt the worst hand in the Western
Hemisphere but their spirit remains
intact
I couldn't wait to get outside and meet
these wonderful people
[Applause]
I just bumped into this gentleman your
name is funny oh thank you come on
remember watch a clip on YouTube you in
a Kevin Hart oh yeah yeah yeah he's
fantastic
you know what you're much taller than
Kevin Hart yeah here yeah here on you
yeah what CNN oh and by the way on CNN I
got what this suggestion would you like
to sit you down on I like it I love this
guy's a fan of mine and well you're the
only guy that likes both of us most
people don't like him don't like me this
morning how are ya well what made me
watch you bro I wait a minute why did
you say why did you say my wife made me
watch you it's no no no makes it sound
like what I didn't make you do the
dishes no no no well I wouldn't mind if
she made me do the dishes yeah nice to
meet you in exam 2 my name is James
James yeah you love Haiti
I love yes so okay let's talk about it
president Trump used some really awful
language about Haiti last week he's the
word [ __ ] what words would you use
to describe Haiti well I would describe
Haiti as the backyard of America if it's
a [ __ ] that chump should check out
his backyard according to the history of
this country
yeah and America has had a lot to do it
with the condition of this country yes I
mean it may not be so beautiful there's
trash and garbage a lot of places but
you know the people of Haiti are
brilliant intelligent yeah and loving
people in well-received and creative and
also really funny and it's all really
funny yes oh yeah Asian people and I
think that's their that's what our they
are straight because they make a joke
out of everything yes your whole you've
got a very cool centered vibe yes and I
like that and I want to emulate you do
some yoga
put some yoga into your life yoga yes
bring it here with your back straight
back straight
all right and close your eyes make sure
you're straight now all right and now
just observe your inhalation in your
exhalation and get intimate with
yourself reach up with your breathing I
can animate with myself just this
morning in fact that you are better at
foreign policy than the present United
States right now what's your full name
my name is James Byrd no I wish James
verno was pres the United States right
now oh I really wish that was true
oh geez window pollutes and many of your
dishes clean backyards and sitting up
straight I listen to your breath plus
he's been endorsed by self-pleasure
common of them so please help make James
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
apparently there's a group over here
that's really angry they saw me they
know I'm American and they see my camera
crew we're being told through our
interpreter that when Americans come
here they only shoot the bad things
which obviously is not what we want to
do can you maybe you could tell them the
reason I've come to Haiti success been
on IET is because I and a lot of
Americans are angry about what President
Trump said members of a computer look on
there Kelly Foster from Startalk didya
so I wanted to come here and show
positive great beautiful things about
Haiti full tourism being lovable talking
about a positive quiet but I understand
why just seeing an American right now
with a camera would make people angry
well American fashion
I actually wrote a speech and tried to
write a speech in Creole but I can't say
it very well about my intentions here
Bonjour IET okay the Cebu okay so when
continent build boom from country toot
moan and a pizza okay map EC and poop
catch you may 8000 Eve pakora shuang yan
low President Ma toot
Brett is Annette
[Applause]
so you'd go head and tell Trump to go
find out about dessaline about this
aleena of this island yes he doesn't
listen to me try this Arlene of this
island yes Conan's translator lefty
better when an American comes to my
country to lecture his president about
Haiti's history and he thinks I said
this happened because he clearly never
heard of our first leader they saw him
this is the face on me but I will try
and tell her I know a way that we can
get Trump to watch this message right
now okay so we go no occasional about
film for cute womp put that onto our
face so take care of that right now so
that we know Trump watches and bang here
you go
[Applause]
[Applause]
like Thanksgiving at my house
[Applause]
you